you
you
I'm an engineer on google plus and i'll
be talking about the work we're doing
with CSS modules for those who have
already seen this at CSS conf sorry this
is basically the same talk I updated a
few things based on questions from there
so the problem that CSS modules is
trying to solve is not a problem that's
unique to Google+ or Google it's a
problem of all very large applications
this is just a sampling of some of the
top level pages and within each of these
pages we have lots of features and that
adds up to lots of JavaScript and CSS
and as you can see from these numbers
here we have a ton of CSS and we have a
problem to solve the other problem that
module system addresses is a problem
that almost everybody struggles with
which is writing maintainable CSS and we
have both of these problems in Google+ a
lot of CSS too big too slow and since we
are manually curating our CSS in our
build files it's brittle and prone to
reordering when developers refactor
their code so this has resulted in many
broken you I regressions in our QA and
because developers cannot rely on a
deterministic cascade order they have to
resort to things like specificity which
gets ugly so this talk is about the
module system that we've developed the
primary goal being CSS size initial load
time building a body will system is a
lot more straightforward if you have
absolutely no shared code at all let's
say we didn't share any code between our
pages on Google+ then you could simply
make each page a module and download it
and it's much more straightforward but
in reality we have a lot of shared
styles and if you don't have a lot of
shared styles on your site you're doing
something wrong so we had to develop a
dependency system to handle this and
that itself has been a huge win and it's
really improved developer productivity
because now our developers can rely on
this deterministic cascade and not be
fighting specificity so we haven't
launched this a module system fully to
our entire site we have launched it
pages and we've seen significant
performance improvement in terms of CSS
size the GSS the CSS preprocessor we use
internally is called closure style
sheets and we call it GSS internally so
if i say GSS in this presentation I
really mean CSS so we've said that when
you know we have shared code we want a
dependency system but to build an
effective dependency system you have to
know what the shared code is and this is
not always obvious for a really large
site you might notice that there is some
similarity between a button and a menu
item but it's not obvious what those are
but you can start with the obvious there
are a lot of repeating UI elements in a
lot of sites and we have a ton of these
and these are things like buttons icons
or what's called the media object with
image on the Left text on the right so
Google Plus is a social network the
primary content on the main page are
post from people in your network and
every post is contained in its card and
every post has the same characteristics
the circular icon with a person posting
there are buttons for + well for
uploading Andrey sharing this comment
activity on the left hand side there's a
box that you would start typing in if
you wanted to share something with your
network and we call this the share box
so this is a completely different page
it's my profile page and it's got this
unique element on the top right going
but the rest of the page is looking very
similar there are posts the posts have
the same characteristic same components
and again there is a share box another
page on our side community page and it
has a description of the community in
the top right card and there's a panel
on the left but the rest of the page is
again posts and the share box I get
another page photos and this looks very
different at first but then if you look
on the right panel you see the same
recurring UI elements so you get the
point we have a ton of shared components
across our entire site but this is not
everything in terms of shared styles in
addition to this we have
forms and colors that we share across
all of Google Plus and in addition to
that we have lots of shared Styles
across all of Google and these are for
things like buttons checkboxes menus
toolbars etc so that as you're visiting
different Google properties like search
or maps you have a somewhat consistent
look and feel so now we have these
somewhat competing goals because our
developers want to split all of this
code by project boundary because all of
those features i showed you the home
page the profile page photos they're all
developed by completely different teams
but we the infrastructure people want
them to share all of these common styles
so this is all the more reason we need a
dependency system we need a systematic
way for them to be able to reuse all
this code we cannot just depend on
developer discipline so let's take the
example of the home page in the
community page we know that they both
need to render post they both need to
render a share box and so they have some
common code for that in addition to that
they have unique UI elements for their
own pages but for this common code we
want them to be able to write this only
once download it only once to the
browser and download only the minimum
code they need so let's step back from
CSS and consider all of the code needed
to render one of these pages so for the
home page we know we need Templars
JavaScript and CSS everything that the
browser needs to render this page so for
the home page we know we need to render
posts share box and other home page
specific elements so one goal here is we
want our initial page to be super fast
we want to download only the minimum
needed when we visit the homepage and
later on when we visit another page like
the community page just download the
incremental code needed for that and
nothing more so there is a solution for
this in JavaScript and it's called jjs
modules and it solves exactly this
problem of incremental download an
example familiar to do javascript
developers would be AMD common jas and
last year ajs conned my co-workers Malta
and John
unveiled the Google open source module
server however there is no solution here
for CSS and the question is can be used
the same solution so there is a catch in
CSS which is safety so let's say you
visited the home page and then you was
in the community page if you're not
careful about how you write your CSS you
could potentially override the styles of
the home page and distort that page so
for example that there was a button with
the same selector on both sides and the
community page added style to the same
selector and now your home page button
is broken so now an additional goal we
have for CSS is that we want absolutely
no UI regressions on the previous page
as you visit new pages so we're starting
to see that CSS is not so simple the
challenges here include a safety issue
that I just mentioned in addition to
that we know we have all of these shared
depths and we need a dependency system
but there is no notion of dependencies
and CSS and almost every other language
seems to have a dependency system and
this like require and common jas or
import of java and python so then the
question is how do we depend on what we
need and how do we depend on only what
we need so we recap our goal here as we
wanted to deliver the minimum amount of
CSS you want to do it incrementally and
safely and the challenges are bundling
the CSS with its dependencies
downloading it as needed and safely
composing it so we are really saying
what we want is a module system we want
to dependency system so we can bundle
all the CSS with the steps we want an
assembly and serving system so we can
download it and safely compose it so
let's consider each of these challenges
starting with the bundling so if we
define a module as a bundle of CSS it
supports a page of our sign downloaded
together and we are already identified
some of our CSS dependencies as the
shared code this is CSS that comes from
shared components from things like
shared fonts and colors and the common
CSS libraries been in our case these are
typically the Google wide style
libraries
so before we dive into our solution lets
rule out the naive solutions that don't
work for us we cannot just become we
don't want duplication so we can't just
add an additional CSS at import in every
page and duplicate Lee download all of
those shared Styles you already seen we
have a ton of shared Styles if you want
to include only what we need so if there
are like seven variants of the share box
measured and if my page just wants to
depend on one of them I want to include
just that and nothing else in addition
we don't want to take every single style
that's ever shared across our entire
site and bundle it together in a single
shared depth smart you because this is
very quickly going to become very big
and very unmaintained bull so starting
with dependencies we know the first type
of dependencies are shared components
and we have a bunch of these but what is
the CSS that we need for these it's not
easy to tell because we are writing our
styles in a separate stylesheet but we
do know what templates we need and we do
know what javascript we need and these
in turn can point us to the CSS that
they need so essentially if we associate
the CSS with the JavaScript and with the
template and create a component and the
CSS can just come along when we depend
on this component and this is similar to
the idea of CSS Legos that's fairly well
Lola CSS community where you identify
bundles of CSS for reusable widgets the
new concept here is we wanted to be
self-contained you wanted to include its
templates and it's JavaScript and this
lets us have the framework do all the
heavy lifting and we're not relying on
developer discipline so we've said that
we want to have dependencies from
template to CSS and from JavaScript or
CSS so we've created our own custom
syntax for this we use closure templates
and on Google+ and so we've created a
require CSS syntax that just gets added
to the template and it points to the
namespace off the CSS that it needs
in addition we created a syntax in
JavaScript to the annotation that again
points to the CSS namespace that it
needs and this can just as well be
expressed with AMD syntax so once we do
this bundling of components and pointing
to components from these visits we
essentially end up with a component
dependency graph something that looks
like this and this thing can extend to
our entire site so we have a complete
component dependency graph across our
site so the next category of
dependencies are things like fonts and
colors and layout things that are that
can be expressed as constants and
mix-ins so there is pretty standard
syntax for this in most CSS
preprocessors and this is the
intemperate directive in SAS we use
close your style sheets in Google+ and
our syntax is called etro wide and it
required so let's say you have some name
some CSS namespace called profile base
and it's exporting a constant called
profile update background color or
something and then you have some other
CSS that wants to use this concert in a
style all it has to do is at require
profile based namespace and this notion
of fonts and colors and constants
expressed in namespaces Maps well to our
CSS dependency graph so if you have
constants that are applicable only to
the photos page only the photos page
will depend on these and then if you
have other common constants that are
need where multiple pages then they can
all depend on those we still haven't
talked about shared CSS libraries yet
and we'll come back to that in a minute
so moving on to the next challenge which
is safely composing CSS in the browser
so before I del too much into safety I
feel like I need to set the background
here with kind of the core concepts of
CSS which are order and specificity the
sea and CSS is for cascade CSS is
inherently order dependent if you have
base tiles and you have overrides the
base tiles must be ordered before the
overrides and special
the city can trump order so let's say I
have a text hello world wrap in a div
and it has two classes blue and red with
the colors blue and red the color of
this text is going to be blue and the
reason for this is that it is the
Cascade order that dictates styles and
not HTML I continue to see developers be
confused by this because this is not
intuitive so now if I add an additional
class called hello in the same tag and I
update my red selector to hello dot red
and now the text is read and this is
because i have just bumped up the
specificity of the color red this is
generally not a great way to do over
right because you can get into trouble
then you want to again override this so
the next time you want to override again
you're basically fighting the previous
specificity and which is why this is
famously call the specificity Wars so
the basic rules are as much as possible
we want to use the Cascade to dictate
styles and not specificity there is a
known body of work thanks to the work
done by Nicole Solomon on
object-oriented CSS there are some basic
guidelines and we have found these to be
fairly accurate in our own experience in
Google+ and these the guidelines are
minimize your selectors reuse as much as
possible simplify specificity it should
be as low as possible and keep your
rules to have the same strength use the
Cascade to override styles not
specificity so really what we want is a
framework that enables us to use to
basically allows us to develop using
these guidelines it should enable simple
selectors it should enable rules of
equal strength and ideally the framework
itself should order the Cascade
correctly so we the developers don't
have to worry about specificity so let's
consider the concrete example of
overrides for a button let's say we have
a button it has some shared styles
we have different pages on our site that
want to style this slightly differently
for the sake of this example let's say
each of these pages wants a slight once
a different color so there's many ways
for overriding styles and CSS and this
is a list of them and there's pros and
cons so we're going to take a quick tour
of these examples so the standard way to
do this is you want to extend the base
button styles with your context specific
style so in this case say the prove that
you would add a profile button class and
then you might use a compound selector
like profile button got standard button
and we've already said why this is not
the ideal practice because this is prone
to clashes now let's say the profile
page again wants to override the button
in its context if the button appears on
the header verse a sidebar it should
look differently and that's when you
start getting into trouble here another
way to do this is using descendant
selectors so you would say profile post
space start standard button and the
problem with this is now you are tying
your CSS to a predefined HTML structure
you could use tools to do this and most
CSS preprocessors have the notion of
mix-ins so if you use a mix in here and
expanded that it would essentially put
the styles in line in the profile
context on the event context and the the
nice thing about this is that now you no
longer need the standard button but on
the flip side this is a lot of
duplication this is not going to scale
for our site another possibility is it
using the sass at extend directive so
you would create a place mall or
standard button and then you would
extend that in the profile context and
in the event context and this compiles
to something like this where sass will
create a single rule with all the shared
styles and this is much better now much
better than mix-ins you know law you no
longer have the duplication problem but
now there is a single selector for each
of these and in in our case when we have
this big CSS dependency graph this
selector is going
to show this rule is going to show up in
a shared module in our graph and ideally
for our dependency graph we want to keep
context specific and features specific
selectors in their own modules so
finally one way to do this is simply add
an additional class keep the standard
button and just add more context
specific selectors with the override but
here now you have to rely on the correct
CSS cascade order this is in fact our
preferred solution for what we do in
Google+ and we let the framework order
the Cascade correctly using it require
so in this case where the profile button
wants to be ordered after the standard
button all that has to do is at require
the standard button so we essentially
now expanding the semantics of act
required to include ordering and we've
considered some alternatives here like
expressing this ordering in our
JavaScript or in our templates but that
starts to look awkward and we like this
approach because it meets our
requirements it minimizes the number of
selectors and now we have rules of equal
strength so we still haven't looked at
how we do overrides and components the
example we just looked at was the case
where we have a shared library of styles
and we had some shared button styles
what if you do about shared components
so let's say you have an icon component
that's used in multiple contexts like
many widgets want to use that same icon
but they want to override it and have it
look slightly differently in each
context so in the when we create a
component dependency graph the nodes in
the graph will have the bundled template
in the JavaScript and the CSS for this
and then later on we essentially flat in
this dependency graph to the Cascade but
we preserve order when we do that so now
you can see why the Cascade order is
correct and so now we have styles that
show up in the right order and that's
great which
haven't said how we are overriding so we
typically either use additional classes
or descendant selectors additional
classes require you to plumb your new
class down to the components template
but if the component is going to be
overrated in almost every context it's
used in then that's actually better
because it exposes sort of an API the
other way to do this is use a descendant
selector and here we are not tying it to
the HTML structure / Saviour tying it to
each context at the different pages need
alright so so far we've covered the
types of CSS dependencies we have its
components constants and mixes and
libraries and we've looked at the
dependency syntax in each category and
we've looked at the star how style
overrides happen and we've demonstrated
that the Cascade order is correct so
with the addition of the shared CSS
libraries now we have a complete CSS
dependency graph for our site oh and by
the way we don't just rely on developers
to do the right thing here in terms of
adding the dependency syntax we actually
do enforce it and this is using tools
and tests and compiler passes so for
require CSS we have tests that create
maps out of the CSS namespace classes
and it will the test will fail if you're
missing a require CSS basically and
similarly for the Ettrick wire we have
compiler passes that enforce some things
like you cannot simply keep overriding
the same selector in multiple contexts
you can't just say dot foo and then
again dot foo and etc also we want to
order like we want to enforce the
ordering of classes in the HTML so that
goes back to our original hello world
example like you'll be forced to express
that ordering with that require all
right so so far we've covered the
dependency system part of our module
system we've looked at namespaces we've
looked at how we express dependencies
using require CSS that require so now we
move on to assembly and serving so I
on this a little bit earlier how we have
a dependency graph and how that gets
flattering to a cascade the additional
thing here to note is that nodes in the
like bundles of nodes in this graph get
compiled to modules and those modules
get ordered correctly a module is a
group of CSS the downloader together and
we always make sure that the shared
dependencies are downloaded with the
first module that needs it and we have
analogous JavaScript modules for our CSS
modules so the two requirements of a
serving system that we really want you
want to minimize the number of requests
and we want cashable responses so one
thing to note here is that the client
has the knowledge of the dependency
graph so it can ask for the modules that
are deeded so let's say you're making
here on the first page on Google+ let's
say the community page and you make
requests to the server you're
essentially constructing a request URL
that has the list of modules that you
need to show that page and then on the
server the list of modules gets
concatenated down to a single response
and so you're serving a single response
and again the next page if you go visit
another page because you have stayed on
the client that knows what my deals have
already been requested and cached you
only request the additional modules on
the next round and one thing to note
here is that this addresses our original
problem of safety we don't get into the
problem of oh I'm on my next page and
the new styles of the community page are
killing my button that doesn't happen
because we've already done the hard work
of creating this dependency graph we've
identified the shared styles we've
extracted them out into the depths so
always the depths are present beforehand
so now this solves our problem original
problems of Google+ which is big CSS
bundles that's low and specificity Wars
manual curation maintainability
so these are some open source resources
that you can look at we use close your
style sheets which has our EDD provide
an Det require syntax and we use closure
templates which doesn't have our require
CSS syntax yet but will in the future
thank you that's all Thank You CD do it
questions I should be so going back a
bit to the performance you mentioned you
just want to download the additional CSS
that the page needs how about cash
ability of URLs how do you tackle them
do do you just add more URL so that the
browser has to cash in you like
proliferate a lot of URLs that in style
sheets that the browser caches with this
approach like I said we are cashing the
previously downloaded modules so the
next URL will not have the modules that
you already downloaded before so you
basically get caching and you'll leak at
the incremental modules you need on the
next one right so so that's the separate
requests yeah so the next request will
have the additional modules and so on
the next and if you go to another page
you won't get there you already cashed
my deals from the first two pages and
now you'd only get the additional stuff
in the third page and so on sorry
hello should be i want to thank you for
your presentation thank you i work for
and exits kinda russian google might be
heard of it and actually i work at a
team which are expensive for quite
similar thing we created methodology and
tools and some libraries which provide
almost to the same ideas to reuse blogs
and to share same components among all
our services we have about i think 200
of them and i have got a question right
now you said that you share a lot of
same components but all of them are in
google+ just one service but i'm sure
that quite a lot of different services
at google uses the same things and are
you going to share your same components
among all the services and if so how
would you do it yeah so we actually do
that already so things like the +1
button and stuff they show up in
multiple play all over google and like
one search and stuff so we're already
doing that so we do have a shared well
we're still sort of pushing towards sort
of you know making them as encapsulated
and kind of bundled as possible but we
do have some of these like the +1 button
that has you know template in javascript
and CSS and now many different things
can point to that but my question is a
bit wider i think because i'm sure that
different services uses different
technologies for templating writing
JavaScript with different approaches and
so on and it's not so easy to share same
challenge London yeah that's absolutely
a problem right so if something if
another like if maps is using a
completely different templating system
then yes that does break down there they
cannot just use it use the entire
component they can only use the styles
and the JavaScript and import that so
yes we haven't solved that yet but still
you are going to try
and if so I think we can share our ideas
and maybe we can borrow something from
you I absolutely love to chat later no I
think we can find a lot of helpful
things between our approaches and
compiling looking our efforts thanks
thank you very much all right if that's
it uh thank you so much TV
you